not everyone wants to see you
succeed some will even go out of their
way to see you
fail learn to be
sufficient and realize you are a mortal
who will suffer horribly later if you
don't become independent and
resourceful stop worrying about what
other people
think honestly who gives a
[__] keep to
yourself stay away from
idiots stupidity is
contagious your friends want you to do
good but not better than
them rest don't care
learn how to say [__] it and mean
it don't say yes to everyone to make
them
comfortable check with yourself too
before you
commit many people don't like you is
especially if they see you as a
competition rule your life with your
mind not with your
feelings every bad decision we have made
in life there was more emotion in it
than there was mind every single
one always listen to your gut
somehow it knows many things that you
wouldn't
expect know your worth never put
yourself in The Bargain Bin or that's
where others will value
you time truly
flies be grateful always because it can
always be worse live like there's no
tomorrow and do what you
love the money will
flow don't get bogged down in
regrets no one is
perfect don't chase happiness just stay
positive and you will experience
Joy pay close attention to those who say
say they love you because so often they
don't they only use
you trust in yourself and your first
instinct on
decisions lower your
expectations having high expectations of
yourself and of others is a recipe for
chronic dissatisfaction in
life
focus on you people come and
go if you don't control your mind
someone else
will sometimes the things that break
your heart end up fixing your
vision loneliness is the price you pay
when you start to improve yourself
self be proud you survived the days you
thought you
couldn't not everyone will like you
that's
life stop telling people everything most
people don't care and some secretly want
you to
fail be
kind but don't let people use
you it is better to be hated for what
you are than to be loved for something
you are
not don't go broke trying to impress
broke
people stay away from people who make
you feel
lonely no company is better than a Bad
Company make peace with your past so it
won't screw up the
present don't compare your life to
others you have no idea what their
journey is all
about never underestimate the power of
stupid
people
no one is going to figure out your life
it's your
responsibility when nothing can go wrong
it
will if you are a so-called nice
guy you will be screwed up in the worst
possible way you can ever think
of you will be pulled down out of
jealousy don't get surprised it's
normal a bad phase of your life can
start at any
time most of the time you have to
swallow the pain and learn to grow up by
yourself don't make one person the
center of all your happiness don't make
them the reason why you are happy
because once that person walks away from
your life you're left with
nothing trust
wisely and not
blindly your friend's problems become
your
problems the smaller your circle the
less [__] you have to deal
with
never expect someone to catch you when
you
fall even if you work on you for
you the truth is everyone is going to
hurt you you just got to find the ones
worth suffering
for be proud of how hard you are
trying Don't Look Back you are not going
that
way don't depend to much on anyone in
this world because even your own shadow
leaves you when you are in
darkness work at your job and make a
living work on yourself and make a
fortune at your lowest
you realize a
lot remember some of the best times of
your life haven't even happened
yet this is your world shape it or
someone else
will bad habits are like a comfortable
bed easy to get into but hard to get out
of
no one is too busy it's only a matter of
priorities if it keeps you happy keep it
quiet the best thing I ever did was stop
telling people what's going on in my
life striving for Success without hard
work is is like trying to harvest where
you haven't
planted never Force don't beg and don't
chase life is like a book some chapters
are sad some are happy but all are
necessary for the full
story learn how to change a flat tire on
your
vehicle
if you don't value your time neither
will
others the strongest people are not
those who show strength in front of us
but those who fight battles we know
nothing
about the pain you feel today will be
the strength you feel
tomorrow turn your wounds into
wisdom when writing the story of your
life don't let anyone else hold the
pen don't put off important medical
checkups practice
self-compassion we are all human and
everyone makes
mistakes time he feels almost
everything give it
time a good laugh and a long sleep are
the two best cures for
anything sometimes you win sometimes you
learn forgiveness is not for the other
person it's for your peace of
mind
sometimes we're tested not to show our
weaknesses but to discover our
strengths the calmer you are the clearer
you
think work on you for
you the truth is everyone is going to
hurt you you just got to find the ones
worth suffering
for be proud of how hard you are
trying don't look back you are not going
that
way don't depend too much on anyone in
this world because even your own shadow
leaves you when you are in
darkness work at your job and make a
living work on yourself and make a
fortune at your lowest you realize a
lot remember some of the best times of
your life haven't even happened
yet this is your world shape it or
someone else will
bad habits are like a comfortable bed
easy to get into but hard to get out
of no one is too busy it's only a matter
of
priorities if it keeps you happy keep it
quiet the best thing I ever did was stop
telling people what's going on in my
life striving for Success without hard
work is like trying to harvest where you
haven't
planted never Force don't beg and don't
chase sometimes you win sometimes you
learn
if nobody helps you do it
alone take your financial life
seriously money is a defense to a lot of
challenges be selfish with your time a
lot of people don't deserve
it what other people think of you is
none of your business
business you can't go back and change
the
beginning but you can start where you
are and change the
ending being alone gives us an
opportunity to reconnect with
ourselves sometimes you need to stop
seeing the good in people and start
seeing what they show you
don't pretend to be better than you
are live life at your own
pace life is too short to waste time
hating
anyone your deepest darkest moment may
be the best thing that ever happens to
you envy is a waste of time you already
have all you
need if you don't ask you don't
get do unto others as you would have
them do unto
you if you tell the truth you don't have
to remember
anything life isn't fair
but it's still
good he who is not courageous enough to
take risks will accomplish Nothing in
life don't trust words trust
actions do yourself a favor get rich
life gets easier with money not
time
if you can survive your own thoughts you
can survive
anything if they don't appreciate you
they don't deserve
you learn to heal without venting to
everyone to avoid disappointment expect
nothing from
nobody
everything comes to you at the right
time be patient and Trust the
process failure is a bruise not a
tattoo avoid gossip at all costs it's
poison to your
mind the root of all suffering is
attachment
time always exposes what you truly mean
to
someone stress is temporary but the
lessons you learn from it can last a
lifetime if someone is trying to bring
you down they are already below
you money isn't everything in life but
it can help you solve a lot of
problems no matter how smart successful
and good-look you are nobody likes
arrogance humility is
everything don't regret having a good
heart all good things come back and
multiply don't feel guilty for doing
what's best for
you choose your friends
wisely the fastest way to become better
is to surround yourself with better
people hope for the best prepare for the
worst people want you to
succeed but not more than themselves
no is one of the most powerful words in
existence don't be a people
pleaser you'll be alone in the most
difficult times of your
life these times will make you wise
mature and
fearless no matter how nice or
respectful you are some people will
still talk bad about you behind your
back when you're working for someone
else's
dream you sacrifice your
own no matter what good you do to people
they will only remember your
mistakes to reach somewhere you need to
leave something behind it's best to
leave things at the right time
otherwise you are left with too many
regrets and
complaints you may not realize this but
the people you love are your biggest
weaknesses bad times are actually a boon
because they wake you up to the good
things you never paid attention
to
if you are
impatient life will always be
harder patience can do
wonders trust is easy to build but can
be shattered in
seconds worry doesn't take away
tomorrow's troubles it takes away
today's
peace don't be AF afraid to make a hard
Choice the hard choices are the best you
end up
making the more you spend clinging to
the past the less likely your future
will be any
brighter action is 10 times more
valuable than reading and
planning experience is the best
teacher there never exists a
relationship without
self-interest in short every one of us
for sure is
selfish if you're not dating to marry
you're dating for
heartbreak let that sink in and be in a
serious
relationship respect yourself because
people can see if you don't
if you don't clear your misunderstanding
in time they become the reason for
distance
forever anyone you love can die
anytime cherish
them nothing is ever as easy as it
seems there is no better way to save
yourself than saving money every
day compound interest can do
wonders good things do come to those who
wait and suffer it might take time and
be a long and rough
road but it's completely and totally
worth
it whether it's a machine a house or or
a
relationship maintenance is always
cheaper than
repairing your respect at most places is
directly proportional to your bank
balance we cry over people but what
about time time is also never going to
come back time is
everything and one day it will Define
you things that will
count you your health and your
achievements you make the best decisions
when in pain because fear of
experiencing the same pain again is the
strongest
motivator at your life's darkest moments
you'll see the most
clearly the harder your past was the
more beautiful your future will
be you may not lead a comfortable life
with a single source of
income you need to build
others most of the stuff you worry about
never
happens
you attract what you are you want to
attract better become
better learn to cook a few basic dishes
it's a valuable life
skill patience is
power sometimes you have to let go of
something good to make room for
something better
never tolerate
disrespect not even from
yourself listen more than you speak for
wisdom often comes from
Silence create and stick to a personal
budget kindness is a language that the
deaf can hear and the blind mind can
see worrying is like a rocking chair it
gives you something to do but gets you
nowhere you can't start the next chapter
of your life if you keep rereading the
last
one the best view comes after the
hardest
climb C doesn't always
Roar sometimes it's the quiet voice at
the end of the day saying I will try
again
tomorrow never lose your sense of humor
laughter is the best medicine for the
soul you'll never find a rainbow if
you're looking
down always pay pay off your credit card
debt it'll save you trouble
later the best revenge is massive
success the more you give the more you
receive the heart that shares is the
heart that's
full tough times don't last but tough
people
do
the most valuable currency is not money
but time spend it
wisely a ship is safe in Harbor but
that's not what ships are
for the way you treat others reflects
who you are not who they
are it's not about having what you want
but wanting what you have
don't wait for the perfect moment take
it and make it
perfect believe in yourself and the rest
will fall into
place don't be afraid to take risks and
try new
things life is too short to always play
it
safe always take responsibility for your
actions for it is the mark of a mature
individual take a deep breath it's just
a bad day not a bad
life don't say
someday say now for someday may never
come donate to charity small Acts change
lives a person who doesn't make mistakes
doesn't make anything at
all you cannot change the direction of
the wind but you can adjust your sales
to reach your
destination someday when things are okay
you'll look back and feel proud that you
didn't give up
forgive your old self you've
changed if you don't let go of the wrong
people you'll never meet the right
people God knows when to send you
exactly what you
need no
regrets just do better next time
there will always be someone who doesn't
see your
worth don't let it be
you seek respect not
attention it lasts
longer be careful who you
trust salt and sugar look the
same
remember some things have to end for
better things to
begin time always exposes what you truly
mean to
someone life will separate you from your
friends so appreciate each moment you
have
together being private staying lowkey
and not telling everyone everything is
self-care money is a tool not the
goal freedom is the
goal you are responsible for your own
happiness if you expect others to make
you happy you will always be
disappointed do what no one else can do
and you will become what no one else can
become stay calm you've been through
this before you'll get through it
again a negative mind will never give
you a positive
life if people treat you like an option
leave them like a choice
value experience over possessions
because memories are the real Treasures
of
Life accept what is let go of what
was have faith in what will
be so many people love you don't focus
on the people who don't
you deserve it the career the love the
family the peace the
life your vision will be
blurry but it will grow clear with
time patience is your
ally never forget who helped you in a
difficult
time you alone are enough you have
nothing to prove to
anyone no matter how hard the past you
can always begin
again sometimes you have to go through
the worst to get the
best
be alone until you're
valued take care of your body remember
health is another form of
wealth if you can make a girl laugh you
can make her do
anything hard times will always reveal
true
friends
better days are coming you won't always
wake up in the morning with a heavy
heart your strongest muscle and worst
enemy is your mind train it
well don't
react cut them off
silently someone else's progress doesn't
make you yours any
less don't ever let the same people
disappoint you
twice except that some folks love to
point fingers and blame others you will
be blamed for things you haven't done
and for things that haven't even
happened
yet stop complaining whining and
nagging it's wasted
energy who's listening
anyway realize you cannot control
everything or
everyone but you can control
yourself and that's even
better always move in your own Direction
not according to society friends or
family leave the house messy and the
yard unmowed for the weekend you will
remember the fun not the clean house or
yard make time for
fun learn to say no Be
Frugal eat only real food no wheat and
limit carbs
the more you know the Dumber you sound
to stupid
people pay attention to the negative
signs that people give off and
immediately disconnect from
them it will save you a lot of pain and
more
importantly wasted
time
never take the responsibility that does
not belong to
you never sell out and trust your
instincts also most importantly never
take loved ones for
granted have firm boundaries and be
Discerning about who you let into your
life
if you want to help yourself find
someone worthy to
serve through service you gain
experience contacts and a reputation as
a reliable and accountable
Ally it is only through an
apprenticeship that one becomes a
master by real estate let and anything
you can
afford the less possessions you own the
happier and less burden you will have in
your
life life is often very
ambiguous sometimes there isn't a right
or wrong decision or
Choice things are not always completely
clear
you may not get the answer so you just
have to wing
it don't leave someone to teach them a
lesson leave because you learned
yours life is far from over but it's
very short
too if you want to do something don't
delay but don't sacrifice what you want
for what you want right
now when in doubt just take the next
small
step make and keep friends with the
people you want to
emulate not the people that you think
will be most likely to accept
you the people you associate with Will
shape your future
be careful who you marry and even more
careful who you have kids
with slow down and realize that mistakes
are essential to learning
anything get yourself together before
you get any older the older you are the
harder it is to
change no one cares except
family start saving your money don't
spend it on homes you can't afford fancy
cars and running your credit cards to
the
max in the end you'll be much happier
nothing is actually as bad as it seems
or as great as you think it will
be take good care of your health without
Health nothing will matter no amount of
money can bring you Joy if you are
suffering m marry before 30 have kids
before
35 work and earn actively and
sufficiently till and Before
40 make passive income workable before
50 plan to retire from work activity
before
60 do everything for family but expect
nothing from it not even from
spouse
you'll never be sorry for telling
someone you love them do it before it's
too
late save a little money every week or
month nothing gives you happiness like a
financial buffer believe it or
not if it ain't broke don't fix
it
be loyal or stay
single that's
simple expect nothing appreciate
everything be grateful for the little
things in your life to find inner
peace do your best and Trust the
process the harder you work the luckier
you will
get never take anything
personally what others say and do is a
projection of their own
reality be forgiving be understanding
but do not be a
fool never say maybe if you want to say
no
when someone shows you who they are
believe them the first
time your self-respect has to be
stronger than your
feelings don't let success go to your
head don't let failure go to your
heart the best way to respect yourself
is to discipline
yourself if you are a giver remember to
learn your limits because the takers
don't have
any don't waste your time with
explanations people only hear what they
want to
hear accept criticism but never accept
disrespect
never give up on something you really
want it's difficult to wait but it's
more difficult to
regret when you are angry Stay
silent you have three choices in life
you can watch things happen make things
happen or wonder what the hell happened
stay strong even when things Begin to
Fall
Apart stay
strong you're being judged no matter
what so be who you want to
be you don't have to win every
argument agree to
disagree
no regrets just
lessons no worries just
acceptance no
expectations just
gratitude life is too
short the calmer you are the clearer you
think the more you are interested in
others the more interesting they find
you to be interesting
be
interested if you are not falling down
occasionally you are just
coasting hatred is a curse that does not
affect the hated it only poisons the
hater release a grudge as if it was
poison we suffer more in imagination
than in reality
people change Love Hurts friends leave
things go
wrong but remember that life goes
on learn to say no without explaining
yourself be a good person but don't
waste your time proving
it
never tell your friends your plans stop
putting too much trust in them don't let
anyone know what you're doing until it's
done if you want to be trusted be
honest the only person that cares about
your hopes and dreams is
you the only person that is going to
make them happen is you
forget what hurts you but never forget
what it taught
you mastering others is
strength mastering yourself is true
power even the nicest people have their
limits your direction is more important
than your
speed control your thoughts or your
thoughts will control
you don't
overshare privacy is
power don't make a permanent decision
based on temporary
emotions to be the best you must be able
to handle of the
worst as long as you are alive no
obstacle is
permanent you learn nothing from life if
you think you're right all the
time stay
patient the best things happen
unexpectedly never regret a day in your
life good days give happiness bad days
give
experience worse days give
lessons and best days give
memories life is a one-time offer use it
well be yourself people don't have to
like you and you don't have to care
free yourself from society's advice most
of them have no idea of what they're
doing first it hurts then it makes you
stronger normalize walking some paths
alone because goals are
personal the family you create is more
important than the family you come
from life is short live it love is rare
grab it anger is bad dump it fear is
awful face it memories are
sweet cherish
them just because you miss someone
doesn't mean you need them back in your
life missing is a part of getting
over before you are old attend as many
funerals as you can bear and
listen nobody talks about the departed's
achievements the only thing people will
remember is what kind of person you were
while you were
achieving
have at least one person in your life
who gives you honest
opinions it is good to be generous
benign and
magnanimous but there's a limit or
you'll be taken for
granted holding on to things will always
make you more
stressed the things won't happen in a
certain way just because you want them
to happen that
[Music]
way learn from what people do not from
what they tell
you don't react in Anger
immediately wait for it to
subside what said or done in Anger is
irreversible don't over
share privacy is
[Music]
power don't regret the past cuz at that
moment you did your
best see people for who they are not who
you need them to
be never jump to
conclusions be Discerning and let people
show you their true
colors
never Overlook
contempt when someone views you with
contempt and talks to you like you're
beneath them they will likely do you
harm whether relationally socially or
physically remove that person from your
life never lend money because you might
lend it to friends for a few days but
retrieve it from from Fools for
years never share your problems with
friends before finding a solution no
matter how challenging it
is don't show your
weaknesses people will enjoy the
show don't be weak in front of
them listen to the people who tell you
what you don't want to
hear self-pity is dangerous stay away
from
it just because you are going through
hell right now doesn't mean you will
never smile
again pain is purely
temporary you spend all your health
initially for wealth and then you spend
all your wealth for one day of good
health holding grudges will never harm
people you hate Only
You time defines you you will not be
defined well by anything other than
time time is the most powerful
force how hard you fight it will do what
it wants to
the only constant in life is
change embrace it and you'll
grow say please and thank you
often you can't change the past but can
shape your future by learning from
it the heaviest burden we carry is the
weight of our
expectations it's better to be alone
than in Bad
Company when you stop chasing the wrong
things the right ones catch
up there are no shortcuts to any place
worth
[Music]
going you never know how strong you are
until being strong is the only choice
you
have do not let what you cannot do
interfere with what you can
do the best way to gain self-confidence
is to do what you are afraid to
do a River cuts through Rock not because
of its power but because of its
persistence
there is no elevator to success you have
to take the
stairs the greatest risk is not taking
one happiness is not something you
postpone for the future it is something
you design for the
present your life does not get better by
chance it gets better by
change you are confined only by the
walls you build
yourself an ounce of prevention is worth
a pound of
cure focus on what you can control and
let go of what you
cannot take time to enjoy life's Simple
Pleasures
it's in these moments that we often find
the most
Joy give without expecting anything in
return the only time you should ever
look back is to see how far you've
come you cannot have a positive life and
a negative
[Music]
mind doubt kills more dreams than
failure ever
will in the face of adversity remember
that Diamonds Are Made Under
Pressure if you get tired learn to rest
not to
quit do not let the shadows of your past
darken the doorstep of your
future do not not postpone joy for the
sake of the future the tomorrow is
promised to no
one the first step to getting anywhere
is deciding you're not willing to stay
where you
are don't chase women instead focus on
your growth values and cultivating
kindness the right person will find
their way to you at the perfect moment
without the need for
chasing never bend your head always hold
it high look the world straight in the
eye the true test of a man's character
is what he does when no one is
watching you don't have to win every
argument agree to
disagree
one day or day one you
decide spend time with the
elderly their wisdom and experiences are
invaluable small
circle private
life and peaceful
mind sometimes we create our own
heartbreaks through expectation
it's okay to make
mistakes mistakes mean you're
trying use
things not people love people not
things even the smallest lie can break
the biggest
trust be kind kind and generous without
expecting anything in
[Music]
return Embrace Solitude as a time for
reflection and
self-discovery not everyone you trust
will be
trustworthy don't be afraid to express
vulnerability it shows
strength learn to handle rejection
gracefully it's a part of
life
breathe it's just a bad day not a bad
life things will get
better just
wait we have four problems overthink
over trust
overshare over
love
you will be disappointed and heartbroken
multiple times but it's how you respond
that
matters don't let anyone ever make you
feel like you don't deserve what you
want you've got to do what's right for
you even if it hurts some people you
love
the days that break you are the days
that make
you make more moves and less
announcements time never Waits it only
urges you to catch up or get left
behind no relationship is worth damaging
your mental
health
depend on
yourself never on
others being too nice breaks
you trust yourself you've survived a lot
and you'll survive whatever is
coming you grow mentally weak when your
life is too
comfortable sometimes
loneliness is the price you pay for
growth
you are who you
are nobody's approval is
needed learn from what people do not
from what they tell
you expect nothing and you will never
get
disappointed
Embrace every opportunity for regrets
come from the chances we didn't
take if you can dream it you can do
it stop telling people more than they
need to
know you meet every single person for a
reason
just let it be if it's meant to be it
will
happen your past was never a mistake if
you learned from
it once you feel free someone avoids you
never disturb them
again people will forget what you said
people will forget what you did
but people will never forget how you
made them
feel some things are meant to cross your
way but are not meant to
stay your direction is more important
than your
speed never fall in love with the same
person twice because the second time you
fall in love with the member memories
not the
person perceive failure as a vulnerable
teacher and a stepping stone to
success celebrate small victories and
Milestones because they pave the way for
bigger
achievements whoever brings you the most
peace should get the most time
never be afraid to treat people the way
they treat
you just be real it saves everyone's
time never think twice about investments
in
yourself they pay dividends for a long
time you need to stop the habit of
doubting
yourself you can tell more about a
person by what he says about others then
you can by what others say about
him your heart will tell you where to
go your head will guide you there safely
use one without the other and you'll get
lost why life will only come around once
so do whatever makes you
happy you can't do big things if you are
distracted by Small
Things remember 5 years ago you dreamed
about being where you are
now think about
it not everybody wants to be your friend
and that that's okay you really don't
want everybody as a friend
anyway you don't always have to be going
being and
doing it's really okay to just
chill give back even if it's donating
your tag sale leftovers or handing a
dollar bill over to someone less
fortunate do it it'll make you feel
good everything happens for a
reason
always do not fear getting
hurt you can't grow if you don't
hurt
don't ruin your health in order to earn
money you will end up spending your
money to recover your health and that is
not
reciprocal be kind to people without
allowing them to take advantage of your
good
nature efforts never go in vain
[Music]
how others see you is not
important how you see yourself means
everything the only way to live like a
king is to work like a
slave everything you need will come to
you at the per perfect
time you came into this huge world alone
and will go out of it
alone hence can make any impossible
thing
possible by yourself
only if you punish the
truth expect to be lied to
you will look back at your life with
much more regret for the things that you
didn't do than for the things that you
did things don't make us happy
experiences
[Music]
do keep your mouth shut whenever you are
happy keep your mouth shut whenever you
are
sad stop comparing yourself with those
who started 10 years before
you focus on your own
Journey you can't go back and change the
beginning but you can start where you
are and change the
ending
if you waste money you can earn it again
if you miss the moment it can never be
returned live life with opened eyes ears
and
heart strong people are always
simple you spend your first 20 years
worrying what people think about you you
spend your next 20 years swearing that
you don't care what people think about
you you spend the next 20 years
realizing that they aren't thinking
about
you never let others know your
weaknesses instead always try to show up
your positives
don't tell your friends that you're
happy don't make them
angry don't tell your enemies that
you're
unhappy don't make them
happy time
flies one day you are 30 the next you
are
50 plan now for what you want 50 to look
like
last but not least you are here for a
reason that you may not
know but be patient you beat a billion
odds by being here be grateful for the
little things in life that others take
for
[Music]
granted